a prophetic dream that changes
everything we knew about game of thrones
and it happens in the very first episode
of house of the dragon
it's no secret that game of thrones
season 8 received an astounding amount
of backlash from fans and critics alike
but the most baffling element of the
entire season might be the fact that the
series finale left so many questions and
answered one of the most obvious
examples of this is the mysterious
backstory of the white walkers a group
of demonic ice creatures who invade
westeros from the far north with an army
of the undead these beings may have
extinguished life across the entire
continent or not for the battle of
winterfell the threat of the white
walkers ends with the death of the night
king at the hands of arya stark
afterwards the series protagonists set
their sights on king's landing and the
threat of cersei lannister and the white
walkers are barely even mentioned as
such we never receive any concrete
answers about who the white walkers
really are or what their purpose is one
of the most mysterious aspects of the
white walkers is their strange
connection to the dragon riding
targaryen family both factions are
integral to the ancient prophecy
involving azor ahai often known as the
prince that was promised now it seems
possible that we might actually gain
some concrete information about this
relationship as hbo's house of the
dragon has already answered a huge
question game of thrones left in its
wake one major mystery at the heart of
game of thrones as well as the books on
which it was based is a motive behind
aegon the conqueror's invasion of
westeros george r.r martin's fire and
blood claims that aegon only invaded the
continent after being insulted by the
storm king agalak durandan and that his
abrupt call to arms was precipitated by
his own belief that the seven kingdoms
of westeros ought to be united into one
nation however episode one of house of
the dragon the heirs of the dragon
reveals that this isn't actually true
and finally gives fans a definitive
answer for why aegon decided to conquer
westeros in the first place king viserys
tells azer rhaenyra targaryen that aegon
the conqueror had a prophetic dream of
the white walker invasion this awful
vision inspired him to invade westeros
as a way to save mankind from
destruction standing beside the skull of
aegon's dragon valerian viserys says
aegon's absolute darkness riding on
those winds and whatever dwells within
will destroy the world of the living
becerrus goes on to say that aegon
called his dream the song of ice and
fire and that the only way for mankind
to survive this wintry threat is with a
targaryen on the iron throne this
revelation changes everything we thought
we knew about the history of house
targaryen as well as their relationship
to the mysterious white walkers house of
the dragon essentially reveals that the
targaryen dynasty was established to
protect men from extinction not out of
aegon the conqueror's desire for control
and plunder this reveal also establishes
that the fates of the white walkers and
the targaryens have been intertwined for
centuries providing more concrete
understanding of why the targaryen
lineage is wrapped up in the legend of
azor ahai a legendary hero prophesied to
save the world furthermore the heirs of
the dragon makes it clear that this
secret has been passed down through each
targaryen generation from one ruler to
the next considering the fact that this
knowledge appears for being lost by the
time the events of game of thrones comes
around it will be interesting to see
what becomes of this particular plot
point as house of the dragon continues
no matter what happens it's remarkable
the house of the dragon has already
managed to clear up one of the many
mysteries left unresolved by game of
thrones